spät gelang in Brüssel die Verständigung
auf einen überarbeiteten Notfallplan zur
Senkung des gaskonsums für einen Winter
ohne Gas aus Russland heute soll er
offiziell bestätigt werden bei einem
Sondertreffen der Energieminister der
Gas Notfallplan der EU-Kommission sieht
vor dass die Mitgliedsstaaten ihren
Gasverbrauch um 15% senken freiwillig
klappt das nicht auch verpflichtend im
überarbeiteten Entwurf stehen nun aber
deutlich mehr Ausnahmemöglichkeiten und
auch höhere Hürden für verbindliche
Sparziele die EU-Kommission hatte die
Fallstrecke für eine Einigung wohl schon
erahnt als sie den Plan vergangene Woche
vorstellte und flehendlich die
Solidarität aller Mitgliedsstaaten
beschworen mit Erfolg
wenn wir einig handeln dann können wir
jede Krise bewältigen eine starke
europäische Antwort ist die einzige
Antwort dabei waren die Vorbehalte groß
heftige Kritik kam aus Ländern die
längst ohne russisches Gas auskommen von
Griechenland Spanien
wir sind solidarisch aber man kann von
uns keine unverhältnismäßigen
Opfer verlangen die Situation jedes
Landes ist verschieden und sie ist das
Ergebnis der jeweiligen Politik bezahlt
von der Industrie und den Verbrauchern
eine Umkehrung früherer Krisen während
zu anderen Zeiten Südländer auf deutsche
Solidarität deutsches Geld angewiesen
waren ist es jetzt gerade auch
Deutschland dass die Hilfe der anderen
braucht der Spieß hat sich definitiv
umgedreht man sieht dass die resortimaus
noch da sind aus der Eurokrise aus der
migrationskrise eine Rollentausch auf
den der deutsche Vizekanzler mit dem
klaren Verweis auf die gegenseitige
Abhängigkeit in Europa reagierte und
sollte es eine Wirtschaftskrise in
Deutschland geben würde doch Portugal
oder Spanien und das Recht nicht Polen
oder Frankreich davon unberührt bleiben
wir können in Deutschland in Europa
nicht mehr national denken jetzt hat
sich gezeigt die Länder der EU sehen das
im Grohe genauso halten Solidarität für
äußerst wichtig auch vor dem Hintergrund
das während des Ringens der Botschafter
über ein Kompromiss der russische
Staatskonzern Gas prom bekanntgab man
werde die Lieferung von Gas über die
Pipeline Nord Stream 1 weiter reduzieren
ab Mittwoch von bisher 40 auf nur noch
20% der möglichen Kapazität Putin so
versteht man das in Brüssel testet
Europas Einigkeit die EU-Staaten so die
Botschaft aus der Nacht wollen wohl
standhalten
schalten wir zunächst nach Brüssel zu
unserem zdf-korrespondenten Florian
neuhahn Florian noch mal schönen guten
Morgen was bedeutet denn diese Einigung
auf den eu-notfallplan
Europa bekommt wohl noch einmal die
Kurve diese Einigung wurde mir auch aus
Diplomatenkreisen bestätigt es ist aber
eine Einigung die mit wirklich vielen
Ausnahmen erkauft worden ist um ein paar
Beispiele zu nennen es gibt eine
Ausnahme für die Inselstaaten Irland
Malta und Zypern die nicht ans Gasnetz
des Kontinents angeschlossen sind eine
Ausnahme dann für die Staaten des
Baltikums die ihr Stromnetz mit Russland
teilen und deshalb besonders verwundbar
sind dann eine Ausnahme für die Staaten
Spanien und Portugal die mit einem
Mangel an gasverbindungen etwa zu
Frankreich argumentieren eine weitere
Ausnahme für Staaten wie Dänemark und
die Niederlande die sagen dass sie
bereits Anfang dieses Jahres ihren
Gasverbrauch reduziert haben und auch
Deutschland könnte sich auf eine
Ausnahmeregel Berufen nämlich das
kritische Industrien nicht in die
Rechnung einbezogen werden sollen also
man sieht diese Liste der Ausnahmen ist
wirklich extrem lang geworden aber man
hat offenbar alles daran gesetzt die
eine Einigung hinzubekommen
und dann hat nur noch Ungarn ist
offenbar erklärter Gegner dieses
Kompromisses aber es reicht eine
qualifizierte Mehrheit der
Mitgliedstaaten und die wird heute
offenbar erreicht der größte Haken aber
bleibt es ist nur eine freiwillige
Vereinbarung für eine Verpflichtung
fehlt bisher die Mehrheit und so wird
auch heute nach dieser Sitzung die Frage
sein ob Europa wirklich vorbereitet ist
auf einen Winter ohne Gas aus Russland
wird auf jeden Fall interessant sein
sich heute das Kleingedruckte dieser
Einigung in Brüssel anzusehen Florian
neuhahn unser crossman vielen Dank für
die Information